hello freak bitches I've been watching
some pro wrestling like that you have he
totally predicted what was going to
happen with his John Cena Brock Lesnar
yeah I knew the thing a lot about it
Brock Lesnar you played it out long
advanced perfectly you knew exactly how
it was going to go down and you're
saying that it sets up something in the
future oh yeah absolutely they offered
me a full-time writing job I can talk
about it now because I'm not getting it
I'm not doing it but a couple months ago
they offered me a full time job to move
to Stamford Connecticut
yeah after one meeting a meeting like
this that was about an hour and a half
at the end they go how would you feel
about moving to Stamford Connecticut for
a one-year job with the WWE writing on
the creative side and I go I'm gonna
have to think about that and it didn't
pan out because I didn't want to move to
Stamford Connecticut and working 9:00 to
5:00 even though it's really good money
and everything but you would have to go
to you drive to LA or drive to New York
right I still do spot yeah which turns
out it's just a 45-minute drive but I've
been but the job is very grueling the
WWE thing you know not it's not like a
TV comedy writing job it's like a I'd
have to answer to Vince McMahon ly good
Tony Oh would you do get stoned before
writing this idea do you think that's
what I'm sorry
probably what would you say to him well
if you want to say well yeah yeah I'd
say yeah I was stoned when I wrote all
the great ideas that you like sir well
you have a point you think Vince would
try to get you on steroids um he'd
probably get me try to get me to eat me
every chance he gets he brought in
Bryson this is from my ranch I shot this
myself this morning yeah well it was a
good money like serious money super
serious money
Wow sanely serious money you came close
I was happy to get the offer I took it
as a victory and I love what I do I love
what I'm doing and it might be Cray I'll
never regret it you know what I mean I
don't know i think you regret it right
now I'm looking at your eyes so ya know
it's kind of a dream job for you yeah
sort of but then again what I do is sort
of a dream job too and giving up this
dream job for that dream job would be
crazy
you wouldn't have to give up this dream
job I'm telling you it would grueling
creepy job unfortunately trust me if it
was if the word on the streets is man
writing for the WWE's the coolest you
can do anything I would have taken it
and I would have lived in New York and
it would have been amazing I would have
traveled to Stamford 45 minutes every
morning on a subway and so we were
living in Stamford yeah it would have
been amazing and I would have had any it
could have it was stupid the amount of
money yeah you don't want to live in
Stamford you know the problem with
Connecticut is it's not really a state
it is a state but let's be honest ladies
and gentlemen you live in a highway
between Boston in New York yeah
absolutely
it's like they put some houses on the
side of the highway and they call it a
town but that's what's really going on
there's not nothing's being done there
nothing's being made there what do you
got you got the Glenn Beck show in the
WWE that's your entire state economy
yeah of course there's some other things
I'm just fuckin around
don't get oh don't get all fuckin i all
stanford ii on me don't get like all
attached and proud of connecticut
connecticut pride we got a fucking email
Joe Connecticut Pride Connecticut sucks
you know it sucks and I know it sucks
there's some great houses there some
nice neighborhoods crazy neighbor I have
my friend Tommy jr. one of my best
friends lives in Connecticut he tells me
it sucks I trust him
it's not a good spot when I used to
drive there from Boston to New York I
would always think like why are people
stopping here yeah WWE but a lot of
people like you know David Letterman
lived in Connecticut and drove into the
city to do his show
that's how he did it yeah but he's like
reclusive you know mmm he likes being he
needs to be away from everybody
he's weird like that and you're not you
missed her out going on that City
partying it up at night yeah doing a
little blow in the morning pep you up
her ass for sure you know me show up on
the campus convince the paperwork that
you wrote on the plane over there yeah
tody this storyline makes zero sense
what kind of storylines when you plan it
did you I know you did I know you
thought about it absolutely absolutely I
wrote I wrote a great storyline where
you know Brock Lesnar and in this past
WrestleMania he beat the Undertaker and
the Undertaker's had a streak at
WrestleMania he never loses at
WrestleMania he was 21 and 0 all-time at
WrestleMania 21 years he had never lost
in this match against Brock Lesnar it's
sort of it was sort of set up so
everybody just assumed the Undertaker
would win then in a stunning move
Brock towards the end of it ends up
beating the Undertaker for the 3 count
you want to see something funny look
that up reaction shots of the audience
that okay but this audience was stunned
people just so I know what else you're
on that audience a fucking simple card
trick oh come on
what are you talking about listen code
Road you're fucking doing silly shit
okay it's all planned out it's obvious
it's not obvious it's definitely not if
it's planned out why would it be on what
was gonna happen I know what's gonna
happen at some peach oh that's not be a
revenge that's not the arena's not
everybody in the arena was offered a
full-time one-year writing job with the
they don't know what's gonna show you an
expert and pro wrestling essentially
I've watched my whole it was sort of
like my replacement for not having a dad
when I was a kid like I would just sit
there and watch these these storylines
and these guys do all this crazy stuff
and I'm sad well I'm sure it was my dad
replaced totally bummed me out
mmm Superfly Snuka was your dad pretty
much Superfly was one of the biggest
things I mean that's what I was doing
off of couches in my tighty-whities when
I was a tiny little boy Bob Backlund I
remember Bob Backlund them the creator
of the crossface Chickenwing which is a
great move man like fucking time of you
invest in this you should get paid by
this I should seriously consider
seriously consider taking that job uh no
I would say no to anybody else but you
you like that shit so much you've always
got those fucking books around like he
read books on the business of pro
wrestling we're on a fucking plane and I
look over there's people reading his
self-help books some folks are reading
novels Toni H is gonna fucking book the
sex and politics lies in headlocks the
unauthorized bio of Vince McMahon what
the fuck are you doing reading awesome
it's about a guy who took a joke of a
show and turned it into a billion dollar
enterprise and wrote it all himself and
it's the main you should look on
pro-wrestling dude you should write a
book a love affair pro-wrestling i love
affair from towing Edgecliff i was
listening to um to uh the opening
Anthony show which is no longer the Opie
and Anthony show now it's a dopey with
Jimmy Norton I don't know well they just
called the Opie and Jimmy show but
whatever um they had this guy on and
he's an author he's he wrote that a card
movie with Kevin Spacey he's written a
bunch of a bunch of different books his
name is Ben Mezrich Maz rich and he was
talking about Russian oligarchs and
about what happened what went down in
Russia during like the fall of the
Soviet Union where seven to nine people
soaked up 50% of the economy of Russia
yeah seven seven or nine somewhere in
that number like no more than ten people
literally had 50% of the Russian economy
and they were just killing each other
they would like kill each other and take
over their businesses
I'll give you had a competitor if like
you were coke you would send your army
over to kill Pepsi and then you would
just own Pepsi - Wow
it was the total complete wild wild west
and I don't know if he's written a book
on this or he's gonna write a book on
this but fucking a man listen to that
shit was skit I bet he has written a
book on I should find out what the book
is Ben Mezrich
Ben Mezrich interesting I wonder what
the direction of the economy and the
trends in everything were before that
exclusive group of people took that over
because it's you know it seems like
we're sort of in a way heading that
direction with our stuff the top
whatever percent has such a crazy amount
of money compared to the rest of
everybody yeah well it's close you know
we're pretty bad but apparently it's
nothing like Russia like the these
Russian oligarchs
they just dominated they just figured
out a way to completely dominate the
entire economy of a giant country
I mean it's listening to him talk about
it was fascinating the shows different
now that Anthony is not there but Jimmy
Norton is so fucking interesting
hysterical and you know an obese doing
great job with it too it's still a good
show this guy Ben Mezrich was
fascinating fuck Russia man is crazy
they were talking about Putin but what a
gangster Putin had to be to come back
and lead the country after he left like
he led the country took off like they
imposed some sort of a term limit came
back like no term limit in buck oh he's
back again like he's this is the second
time running the country like he
installed some sort of a puppet dictator
or a puppet leader when he was gone
and then came back and he's a former KGB
agent like what the fuck man you know
there's a guy that a professional
wrestler named Risa that actually puts
Putin on it on the Megatron on the
titantron every time he comes out and
really gets the crowd riled up Oh Mother
Russia
I promise I'll defeat my victim for you
and it gets the whole crowd to hate him
and then I then a guy comes out and he
rusev usually wins they let the Russian
guy win because it drives the crowd
crazy and then you think anything can
happen after that my favorite thing is
to watch you respond to me talk about
rest what's wrong with you you would
love it and wrong with you I wouldn't
love it you'd be amazed I'll bet you
though I bet you if I showed you a
statistic of UFC fans being WWE fans I'd
bet you'd be shocked because before the
UFC was all over everything one of the
only outlets that and by the way I've
been with the UFC since the beginning
you know what I mean like I mean like
watching it since the hoist days since
hoist and shamrock and all that and
that's because it's it even though it's
two totally different things UFC is
obviously an extremely you know the
crazy sport and WWE is completely
entertainment with you know some
injuries from time to time
you know the it was an outlet for
anybody that wanted some crazy stuff WWE
and UFC fans I bet there's a lot I would
bet you that I'm just gonna wait till
you're done talking this is it this is
my this is my closing statement here it
is I'll bet you that at least 70% of UFC
fans have been or are WWE fan at some
point 70 percent I love when people
throw a statistic around where they have
done zero research just a random number
I believe seventy I do it all the time
by the way yeah 79 90% a fan no I did
they look it's not the goddamn same one
of them is real one of them I didn't
people battling for their life yeah most
difficult contest absolutely another one
is some weird fucking jerk-off thing
that stream guys do when they sit in
front of the TV and pretend they don't
know it's fake right Daymond no I know
it's fake everybody knows it's fake you
don't want to know you shut that part of
your brain off when you watch it you
like like a lizard I went to a meeting
to take a full time writers job I know
it's fake even even if you wrote it you
would still be there while it happened
going I can't believe it I can't believe
you wrote his ad Undertaker you would
thought you would have your fucking
script in your hand and you'd be jumping
up and down spinning around in circles I
can't believe Brock beat the Undertaker
oh yeah real incredible worlds collide
oh yeah I never got to finish so I wrote
a thing to wear Kane The Undertaker's
brother wrestled Brock Lesnar at this
WrestleMania coming up in seven months
or so and loses but Undertaker comes
back tombstone pile drives Brock Lesnar
and they walk off together
amazing swan song they wave to us
hahaha yeah when when you come up with a
move for a guy to win with do you take
into consideration at all the health of
the person trying to attempt that move
it's tough you're right yeah it's tough
because when Brock Lesnar did that
shooting star press flip through the air
and landed on his head I've seen that
yeah I've seen that everybody seen
anybody like who knew about Brock Lesnar
was researching him very likely if you
were going through like Internet videos
and stuff like that you'd run into that
video of him flipping off the top rope
and landing on his head all 300 pounds
of them landed on his head
bang and kept going yeah crazy I don't
know how the fuck he lived I know if you
watch that it looks like he's a dead man
yeah lands on his fucking head yeah
there's some stuff that just can't even
there just probably an inch either way
and he's he can't move his legs and
stuff but he survived it walking music
is so powerful because you could psych
out an opponent with walking music if
it's done properly if it's some if it's
some subtle crazy stuff you know no you
can't a little bit little bit you can
wrestling you look around what is that
can't believe he's playing that is that
Phil Collins I can feel it in here you
think I believe this is my song who took
my song I don't think if you're and if
you're fighting in the UFC and you come
out first
you had your song let's say your songs
like a seven on a one to ten and then
lights go out and Phil Collins in the
air tonight does come in you're not a
little bit like fuck I wish I would have
picked this you know guy he's already
got he's already got one on me it's
already laying at one blow and that's
the intro you are do I need to call
Vince McMahon right now you think like a
fucking pro wrestling fan and I say that
with all due respect I'm not I'm not
hating on it but you think like you you
take enjoyment in that stupidity I know
I do it's entertaining as hell Vince
why are you slipping this is the man's
going to turn your organization around
you're them either and they should call
you the mastermind
and they should make you a character as
well I agree you wear the glows gold
wrestling shoes that's your whole outfit
it's shiny gold I'm the mastermind good
to be here in Vancouver
Oh what's wrong you don't like my plans
for the future bear I can feel it what
is it about all that stuff even though
you know it's total 100% horseshit what
is it about that stuff that's appealing
to you the entertainment Joe if you
watch one of these things you would you
would see what you liked about it you
would have a few favorites and and know
you would know I'd go fucking crazy and
I'd watch lions killing gazelles on
television because that's real that's
what I do I'd grab my laptop and I'd be
like yeah you watch this fake shit all
day I need real I need real I can't get
entertained by fake but that's what TV
shows and movies are they're fake no no
they're not fake sports are real and
that I understand and this is sports
entertainment it's not okay it's not
we're not nobody saying it's really when
you watch Game of Thrones and you watch
a guy get his head cut off you know what
it looks like yeah looks like a guy
actually getting his head cut off it
looks real yeah when I watch wrestling
and I see a guy get hit and go turn to
the crowd I know that's bullshit right
it's offensive to me yeah it's offensive
yeah and the idea of other moves that
happen that are amazing no no no yeah
they're all offensive oh no I know
they'll take athleticism total off but
they're offensive because I'm so aware
it's so in my face this is not really
happening I can't be the guy in the gold
suit holding up the script jumping
around a place going
The Undertaker lost the streak has been
broken that's what you would do you
would freak the fuck out I wouldn't run
around I wouldn't do that I would if you
were hard if I had a gold suit I would
do that but I don't have a coat consider
doing it Vince is fucking up really
needs to make you a part of it I told
Tony when immediately you should do it
and I can't believe you didn't take it
Tony cuz that is like one of the biggest
things for you for you because you are
that
trying to negotiate doing it part-time
from LA that would be awesome that would
that would be best for both sides
because I wouldn't get burned out on it
and they would have awesome great ideas
that are hip and cool and I would have
been able to do what I wanted it hip and
cool whenever God says my ideas are hip
and cool
I'll go hmm are you sure it depends what
ideas he's talking Undertaker has a
scarf but in the hip scarf it's a scarf
with little skulls all over it like he's
a pirate he's drinking a Frappuccino I
never saw this one caring yes
Undertaker has gone Metro metrosexual
Undertaker maybe if you changed maybe
all sudden Tony starts working for them
and every character becomes gay and it
turns out that there's there's someone
who's sprinkling gay dust over all the
other competitors you know there's a
locker room there's and it's he's
turning that's that's a plot that Tony
comes up with he turns the entire roster
gay it turns out there's an openly gay
wrestler and he has gay fairy dust okay
we'll sit in like a leprechauns ball
sack lady red killed a leprechaun and
turned his ball sack into like this are
you ready for this sure him what if I
were to tell you that there is an openly
gay wrestler that blows dust in people's
faces and his name is Goldust
no fucking way there is like their guard
this is real yeah dude this is in the
WWE Dustin Rhodes a third generation
wrestler what's going on his dick that's
gold dust power David you've heard of
horse power
that's like related to Dusty Rhodes yeah
yeah how'd you know about dusty Rhodes
yeah I used to be eight when this shit
made sense
thank you this guy's real please I need
to see more I can't believe I invented a
guy that already exists yeah you could
you should be writing this that's him
entrance out the girl takes off her wig
and row
and he's Sykes's a moment he flirts with
them in the ring and shit like blows and
kisses and they get all riled up and
then he can beat him with shit cuz
they're like all day I'm not gay get
away from me and he's like oh yeah come
here beautiful and I think to the WWE
should hire Michael Sam as soon as he's
done with the Dallas Cowboys the openly
gay NFL player yeah I don't parent he's
not good enough to make the team and
just bring him for the practice squad
they need to bring that dude into WWE
and actually fuck a guy on TV well him
and Goldust
yeah but Goldust is faking it I could
tell look at my gosh tre yeah he's super
straight is super straight I you know
part of me says it's animal cruelty at
the the biggest part like my gut
reaction I look at that should that be
legal Wow
though that's kind of a fucked up thing
to do it's kind of a fucked up thing to
put razor blades in the end of a
chicken's foot stick them in a cage and
another chicken they fuck each other
they should just do fake chicken
fighting so you have a gay chicken come
out in the blonde wig and all right guys
I lost you on that I've got to be real
chicken I just can't believe his gold
guys real I came up with a guy who blows
dust know is that you named it dusty
road yeah but I don't know that he
exists and he's got a brother named Cody
Rhodes who just made the jump to being
Stardust which is the he's like the he's
like another version of gold dust except
now they roll together so he's good to
know now Stardust is more like just like
about the cosmos and like wow I just
can't believe all the magical things
oh yeah he's high yeah
so he's like a stone stone to the gills
oh that's so funny except he's just out
on it you never know do you think it's
possible to Tony he gave me the like Pro
Wrestling yes oh I know for a fact dude
I would know I know the exact match is
the videos that moves the everything
that would that would interest you see
too much real there's some crazy
submission moves that no no no no no
that's the last thing
let me tell you something that's the
last thing you want to show me
don't that'll get me angry I'll be like
that wouldn't work right no defense here
he's a hip escape he can get out of
there nothing drives me crazy er than
like a fake submission move in a movie
that shit drives me nuts you know I
stopped watching Dexter
because fucking what's-his-name from
third Rock John Lithgow John let's go
have this chicken a rear naked choke in
a bathtub and he killed her that way and
I was like oh my god that's the worst
fucking rear naked choke I've ever seen
that's so fake she's not even read I'm
done and I shut it off I walked out the
room and discussed I never watched
another episode of Dexter again Wow yeah
you can't show me a fake rear naked
choke you fucks that that makes me angry
that's like if you were watching a jimi
hendrix biopic uh you know uh not biopic
but like a UH one of those movies where
it's a fake like an actor plays Jimi
Hendrix I guess that's a biopic right
and some dude didn't know how to play
guitar he's like don't you like now
you're not doing it you're not doing it
at all you're not playing guitar that's
what John Lithgow is shitty fucking rear
naked choke did for me
the only reason I think you would maybe
like it in the future is that you like
you know UFC so much in MMA and
jiu-jitsu so much and Tony gets it
together with a bunch of people and
watches it a lot of them watch it as a
joke where Tony I think takes it a
little bit we all watch this a joke guys
like I'm not buying my joke I just see
and recognize what's entertaining about
it and I do like the ideology of
stunning an arena of people sometimes
that happens it can happen sees of you
had to look at the reaction to the
doheny is a three-hour like job
interview for you this is like your
audition tape they should fucking hire
you they should figure how to create
again I need you to pull this up we're
at where are you Vince listen take the
needle out of your ass and hire this guy
you're crazy not to you should have seen
the looks on these people's faces when
Brock Lesnar beat the Undertaker nobody
thought it was gonna happen oh my god
what did they do Tony imagine
if on Saturday the fuck is wrong with
you and nobody thought it was gonna
happen it was amazing it was fake as
fuck dude but nobody thought it was
gonna happen a lot of things are fake
that nobody thought was gonna happen
Tony Oh Charlie time son imagine if that
guy who filled in for that shit's gettin
around on Saturday and he took on
delecia imagine if in the miracle he was
able to somehow land a punch on Dilla
Shawn beat him the place would have been
I mean while it's sort of weird cuz that
Sacramento and that's Dillashaw his
hometown but I'm just saying like in a
neutral field that would have been
stunning and everybody would have known
that they just witnessed history Tony
that would have been real right no it
really Taylor really had a limit it
really knocked out a professional
athlete two guys who've trained to fight
their entire lives right it's real right
all right I understand you you you're so
crazy you by the way the stuff is gonna
sell insurance here you know I know I
understand where your concerns are but
let me just show you the details of our
policy you're a crazy person
no I'm telling you right there's
millions and millions of WWE and I'm
telling you why maybe hunter s Thompson
was just a couple of decades off when he
was predicting the end of the world
those guys I mean it's not easy it for
example Brock was furious when Vince
told him that he wanted him to beat the
Undertaker that day like in real life
like the bet he was and you were there
to see it
no but I talked to somebody who was oh I
bet he was honest with you it's not like
they lie all day every day hmm
Tony's gonna talk to some people let me
tell you well I'll tell you what Brock
was actually mad he was really mad he
read the script introduces bullshit
I'm not beating a fuckin Undertaker some
of the guys that work unlike the
technical side for the UFC work for the
WWE I heard Brock was crying that's
right it's Brock went to the hospital
with the Undertaker cried so hard II
dehydrated him after that match they had
to give him an IV to replenish his T V
thought he killed the Undertaker from
that concussion
was bad bad it was real the concussions
are real you can't classify dashing
uneven bio as a real concussion okay
probably faked a concussion thank you
the daughter take the Undertaker to the
hospital
he's got up Obon even on the day it's a
real boo-boo folks if you don't think
it's a real boo-boo I'll show you the
fucking bandaid on it are you getting my
for your own believe it's like your
pictures up my four-year-old yeah he's a
boo-boo it is a boo-boo it needs a
birthday honey there's milk he's not
even bleeding you don't need a band-aid
I want to bend it okay well band-aid
make you feel better
we'll get you a band-aid did took the
Undertaker and put a band-aid on him
he's wearing a fucking bandit
Antoni hench grew up in a gold suit
holding the script I can't believe it's
a real boo-boo
she's jumping up and down in circles and
Vince McMahon is standing there shaking
his head you call her a purple I'll
fucking pent up with rage that's how I
wrote it oh my god it's a boo-boo look
at the band-aid it's real it's a real
band-aid ladies and gentlemen if you
doubt it what else do you like that
sucks
um see what else do I liked it sucks hmm
I guess I play fantasy football I don't
talk about that a lot
well fantasy football is at least based
on fucking football right she's a real
game yeah people are really trying shit
really happens but nobody knows what's
gonna happen in real sports oh my god
isn't that part of what makes it
exciting you fucking weirdo same thing
about the w/e bullshit you don't know
what's gonna happen
haha you don't know what's gonna happen
you predicted it right 'red know the
writer knows what's going on the writer
knows it's not real it's like a play do
anyways like a plot of musicals no I've
been doing is gayer than musicals how
about that that doesn't make sense
sure does this dudes are hugging they
get all sweaty they're laying on each
other they're N and it's not real okay
ha ha ha ha ha I mean after musicals
guys are banging but you know I don't
know if they're banging I don't go to
those things I'm not in that world
you've seen a musical right yeah I've
seen a bunch of musicals not that is
anything wrong with being gay by the way
but musicals are gay they just are it
really is that it really is unless it's
a humorous musical yeah even then it's
even then he made someone kiss his ass
right uh that's someone else that's a
Photoshop but that's not the real who is
that guy said that it's a fake guy
they're probably one of you out there
just go look for it that's the thing
about the Internet man there's a photo
of you out there somewhere someone's
photoshopped a dick in your mouth yeah
who are you kissing an ass or you doing
something ridiculous and over am I
staying but why did he do that there's a
challenger why did he do that why he
pulled his pants down and made someone
kiss his ass on TV probably that sounds
like something he would do but he did
you know it why are you pretending you
didn't wash that one it spits I think it
I think that was over like 12 13 years
ago something like I weren't there yet
huh no I I can't remember I can't
remember I'll believe it I think you've
been mark that may have been doing that
maybe I'll do that Harry admit don't you
guys kiss his ass look at that is
warious it's like fuck your brother
backyard wrestling kind of game look how
many people in the audience though
that's insane
plus it's been winning the Monday night
cable wars for over 20 years think about
that for a second every Monday night at
wins every single month they pulled TNA
though they pulled TNA from Maya from
Spike that's Vince's competition what's
the problem with TNA I'm just not good
not everything
terrible they're just completely no
what's an ass it's not even in no no
that's what it should be bright but it's
not it's not even in the same ballpark
what is it well they used to have like a
lot of MMA guys would do it like King mo
was in TNA and rampages in TNA it's not
good
no no what's wrong with it bad writing
bad everything could you go over there
maybe ma'am yes oh no no you don't turn
down the WWE TNA listen you could be the
fucking mogul what if they give you a
piece of the action what DNA said listen
we heard you on the Joe Rogan podcast we
like the way you think about wrestling I
think this organization that still has
some life and we're willing to willing
to cut you in on this give you 10% of
the action I don't own 10% of TNA I'm
pretty sure 10% of the TNA wouldn't even
get me what I would have made with the
wwa you son of a bitch yeah they just
lost me video didn't have a TV deal huh
yeah they're done and maybe I'll get
picked up by like lifetime Vince McMahon
beat Ted Turner
what is Ted Turner CNN CNN TNT TBS he
threw Ted Turner at open checks that he
would to just sign any wrestler back and
they were having Wars on Monday nights
they'd go against each other Vince WWE
on the USA Network and TNT had nitro and
Ted Turner said whatever we need to do
to beat Vince McMahon I will write the
check to whoever so they offered they
bought Hulk Hogan they believe this he
believes I was there I was in the room
no I didn't say I was he said he was
willing to spend whatever it takes that
sounds like a plot like a plot in like
these are two different no I'm tuck this
is where it's real this part's real
that's the problem you've cried wolf
through this whole podcast I never said
it was realest about them repeating that
it's not real and money I'm agreeing
with you and now you trying to tell us
that the boogeyman is real that's what
you're doing wrestling's real I said
that is gonna write it how much did Ted
Turner spend millions and millions to
buy good the guys that were already
developed from the WWF he bought all
their biggest guys hoodie bar Hulk Hogan
Macho Man Randy Savage
you know Macho Man Dusty Rhodes
I know Macho Man
slim-jim fan right snapping Dusty Rhodes
he bought them all and how did it do
they ended up winning the wars for a
bunch of weeks in a row they did yeah it
turned it yeah for like a year in a row
and but then Vince uh bought Mike Tyson
and made him referent match at
WrestleMania with Steve Austin and Shawn
Michaels and then it dominated the rest
is history
that's it one move yep